tha
[Musique]
et
bonsoir et bien au sommaire ce soir
gérard depardieu vous ne reconnaissez
pas c'est coluche
invité surprise de dernière minute sans
ptr bretécher gérard de villiers
jean daniel olivier toth edgar morin
jacques laurent kavanagh roger
knobelspiess nadine joly commissaire de
police
j'en perds une claude roy cabu et siné
qui vont dessiner ce soir et des
documents sur bernard lavilliers ariane
mnouchkine est naturellement tous les
invités qui sont sur ce plateau je ne
peux pas les nommer tous mais il y a
beaucoup d'amis de téléspectateurs de
journalistes qui viennent à notre
émission qui reviendront souvent alors
je les nommerai en cours des mille
démission et naturellement ils pourront
parler quand ils le voudront
il leur présente différentes tendances
de plusieurs journaux et il pose des
questions quand ils veulent poser des
questions il y a aussi tous les
téléspectateurs qui peuvent nous
téléphoner vous connaissez je pense
numéro c'est svp 11 11
les téléspectateurs de paris comme de
province peuvent appeler si les sujets
les concernent directement et si ils
estiment qu'ils ont un droit de réponse
possible sur un sujet s'il se sentent
vraiment concernés ne nous posait pas de
question sur n'importe quoi nous serions
vite submergé vous avez vu dans cette
émission un générique qui a été réalisé
grâce à un prototype français
ça s'appelle la paluche est un objet
tout à fait étrange vous le voyez alors
petit cocorico comme fait qu'à but
derrière moi oui c'est ça youpla
cocorico le cocorico français à la mode
en ce moment mais enfin qu'est ce que
vous voulez c'est une invention
française de même que cet appareil assez
bizarre qui est un prototype lui aussi
que nous utilisons pour la première fois
à la télévision avec lequel cabu et
signer vont pouvoir faire des dessins en
direct c'est-à-dire commenter les propos
de
nos invités et dire tout ce qui leur
passe par la tête
alors ces deux objets ont été fabriqués
à grenoble le bravo pour la ville de
grenoble et il y aura un troisième
gadgets électroniques dans l'émission à
partir du mois de janvier
il s'agit du thé lady du vidéo disque
français nous allons faire une grande
première mondiale c'est toutes les
couvertures disponible de l'édition
française seront mis sur vidéo 10 qui
nous suffira d'appuyer sur un bouton et
à la salle instant même dans une scène
une seconde vous verrez apparaître le
livre dont nous parlerons dans
l'émission je crois que ce sera très
utile pour évoquer comme ça mais ton des
classiques des livres qui une citation
que l'un d'entre vous voudra faire
immédiatement l'auteur apparaîtra fait
la couverture du livre de l'auteur à
paraître bon avant de jouer abandonné un
petit peu des gadgets et pour commencer
l'émission tout de même je voudrais pour
situer un petit peu car nous sommes à
20h30 ce qui est un peu insolite je
crois qu'à svp il ya déjà des appels sur
ce problème nous allons montrer un
dessin de sempé art qui peut être
pourrait situer à c'est bien là le
propos est la situation où nous nous
trouvons alors voilà ce dessin de sempé
qu'il ya quelques années vous devez le
connaître rayant loi allez-y coluche
alors alors chers amis maintenant je
voudrais vous poser la question que
doivent se poser tout noté spectateurs
comment votre concept onirique à
tendance kafkaïenne coïncide t-il avec
la vision sub logique que vous faites de
résistance intrinsèque sauvé voilà sans
paix et à combien de temps vous ai fait
ce dessin pas mal de temps ça concerne à
quelle émission et 26 ans donc je sais
pas je m'entraîne pas là
croissant des sages avait fait un des
seuls vous ne lisiez personnes n'ont en
tout cas vous aviez un certain a
tendance à vous moquer des émissions qui
emploie un langage un petit peu abstrait
bon je pense qu'à l'époque j'avais
seulement penser à lecteurs pour tous ah
oui et vous vous disiez qu'évidemment
dans certaines fermes de la lozère on
devait être un peu surpris parfois par
certains invités bon c'est un commandant
les fermes et à loder non non non non
domaine par certains je crois que si
j'ai pour présenter ce dessin c'est
parce qu'effectivement à 20h30 depuis
une vingtaine d'années les
téléspectateurs sont habitués à voir des
variétés bondir que notre émission d'une
émission de variétés ce serait tout de
même mentir disons un on ne sait jamais
hein j'ai racheté l'autre bon on va déjà
on a déjà un chanteur justement je
voulais dire qu'il y aurait des
chanteurs dans l'émission y aura gérard
depardieu y aura il y aura celle à la
semaine prochaine parce que nous ne
sommes pas sectaires mois 1 sur 6 mais
n'a pas pour moi cette semaine et n'a
pas pu dire ce qu'elle savait qu'ils
avaient coluche et cdd qui chantait trop
bien l heure est trop de concurrence
enfin mettons que nous voulons mettre un
petit peu de variété dans les émissions
à défaut d'être une émission de variétés
nous ne sommes pas non plus qu'on
pourrait appeler une émission culturelle
parce que vous savez que le mot culture
dans ce conte emploi
goering sortait son revolver le
téléspectateur d'après les sondages lui
l'appui sur l'autre bouton coluche avait
même l'expression encore plus qu'est ce
que tu fais ce qu'il a dit tout à
l'heure j'ai oublié j'ai dit si c'est
culturel
on se tire nous ah oui goering
tirez-vous voulu tirer et 7,7 et
goebbels
il me semblait aussi toute façon d'errer
n'y aurait dit la même chose
[Musique]